foreign
and we got a special guest today
some of you may know him some you may
not beautiful brother I will tell you
bro how are you doing
something nice
it's such an honor I already said it
before the we even started the parking
the research honor to have you here
you know what you're doing for the Uma
bro and may Allah may Allah recognizing
me a lot put butter on it and Allah
bless you for it I mean I mean bro I
mean whatever you guys
we wouldn't be able to
now pick up our fingers
it wasn't for Allah right we always make
this dry after Salah
Allah
in remembering you now being thankful to
you and perfecting our acts of worship
so whatever you guys see in the world
wide web
no we have to attribute back to Allah
it's still not as much as we want we ask
Allah to make it easy for us to you know
really get down to proper business you
know
I mean do you have the trans liberation
of that
of the Hadith no would you use
in remembering you right yeah
also being thankful towards you
and perfecting our acts of worship
that's that's a translation of saying
the Chinese Liberation like
yeah you know I'm nursing because I'm
not you know I'm a reverse so my
arabic's not it's not very fluent so I
want to be able to read it
I would love that
girl the prophet salallah
a great companion to read this after
every Salah subhanallah I told him I
love you for the sake of Allah
right indeed I love you
I say this to you uh anguh
indeed I love you for the sake of Allah
you know
uh do not leave a single prayer
except after reading the star every time
when you finish the Salah recite this
dire just as the missing somebody is
some told the companion I'm not sharing
with you you know
on the land so with that being said
they're being said
we were talking about this before I had
to bring it up because I completely
forgot but high value man and high value
women in Islam in light of the Quran and
the Sunnah bro the floor is yours by all
means
is the Romney wouldn't say anything yeah
if you guys want to see anything before
stop speaking because I know I think I
think me and Romeo are definitely in to
listen and gain some hikma bro inshallah
I I would like to just preface by saying
what a lot of people think a high value
man or woman is nowadays just so we can
really compare and contrast to what
people think matters and what actually
matters so
high value men and women that's the term
you hear a lot in red pill
um which is unfortunately become more of
a Dean nowadays it's become more of like
an ideology where people will literally
have a question oh you know my my wife
is acting like this my girl girlfriend
is acting like this what should I do
they'll go to some YouTuber online and
like kind of take them like a prophet
and have him answer and say oh just play
these kind of games with her a high
value man in this kind of world is
someone who makes a lot of money who has
a lot of Fame and Fortune he gets all
the girls he wants and that's what they
identify a high value man with now keep
that in mind when Sheikh goes in on what
a high value man really is in light of
the Quran and Sunnah and a high value
woman to them is actually even worse
it's purely someone who is attractive
and will like obey you and listen to you
that's what they'll see a high value
woman as someone who will be loyalty
which is a good trait loyalty but it's
someone who is attractive and basically
nothing more so Sheikh why don't you
please educate us on what high value
really is islamically
um
foreign
I think maybe a good place to start is
that we establish and highlight that
what really matters at the end of the
day is what Allah
thinks of every single one of us you can
be an individual who is considered high
value
amongst all of the creation that are
walking on the face of this Earth
however maybe you are a serpent if you
are somebody who
you know is absolutely garbage if you
want to call it that right in the eyes
of Allah
does that really really matter
right subhanallah right when you even
look at this you know it's such a
profound Hadith when the messages
whoever looks
for the pleasure of others subhanallah
he does things
right in order to please so and so to
get into the good books of so and so
this person and that person his main
concern is what the people think
and in the process of doing so brothers
and sisters who are listening right he
enrages Allah
he enrages and angers Allah with his
actions what did the messenger wasallam
say is going to happen what will the
outcome be Allah will become angry with
him and he will make the people angry
with him as well
right so at the end of the day that was
really really matters is what Allah
thinks of every single one of us and
that which is going to make you
praiseworthy in the eyes of Allah is to
Simply fulfill what he has instructed
every single one of us right
subhanallah you know I came across the
statement of Jose and it became one of
my favorites they honestly did right he
said
it amazes me how one really goes out his
way to please the people to get into
their good books
he forgets that all of their hearts are
in the hands of Allah
meaning Allah can easily change the
state of the heart of what they think
about you
right and we know the Hadith Prophet
salallahu with someone he said
indeed the hearts of the people are in
between the two fingers of Allah Allah
could choose to keep it upright
could choose to lead astray so it's in
the hands of Allah right so as long as
we work towards pleasing Allah
and it's one of the points that I have
written down anyway right uh you know
prioritizing the Hereafter over the
Dunya you will see that Allah
it doesn't necessarily mean that one has
to be known by the people in order to be
considered high value in the eyes of
Allah I don't know if you guys have
heard this statement before I don't know
who actually said it but the statement
goes
how many people are unknown on the earth
nobody knows who they are but they are
known by Allah
right they are known by Allah I always
tell brothers and sisters you just
started practicing right you're doing a
lot of good deeds you may come across an
individual you may walk past a person
who's doing all sorts of sins and it's
so easy that you end up looking down on
the person
right you look down at a person it could
be the reason why you end up falling off
be extra careful how you look at that
individual you look down at him you
never know Brothers right you belitted
him right he could have a secret deed
between him and Allah azzawajal that
nobody knows about
he cries his eyes
you know he you know he cries his eyes
out every night begging Allah forgive me
for my shortcomings I'm trying
and then because of that he has such a
high status in the eyes of Allah as
opposed to you who walked past that
individual with arrogance and pride
foreign so uh I think this is a good
place to maybe start there's so much
more that can be mentioned right what
really at the end of the day matters my
brothers and my sisters and this is
what's going to raise you in the eyes of
Allah
is that you adhere
to what he has instructed you with
right this also reminds me of uh
abdulrahman
you know it's good that you guys
actually mentioned this it just came to
mind literally right now Mecca
right
and he reached an area called usfan
right there's some distance from Makkah
and he runs in
to a uh he called nafir who used to give
service to his son Abdullah
asks the Cali fight
the great Khalifa um
who have you left the people in charge
of
you're now leaving who have you left in
charge
he said an individual called Abdullah
he said who
Abdullah
it's not he's not like a household name
right you know he doesn't subhanallah
ring a bell
so then he told them Allah he's from the
servants that we have
so you're placed in charge A7 imagine
now I think we share the same Queen
right I think you guys are well in
America or in Canada
me and Romeo and Canada
okay and an angle you're in a am I
saying your name right by the way his
name is pronounced angel
wait
and you're in America right
bro you mute bro
yeah right now I'm in France a little
bit oh you're in France okay
so I think in Canada we we both share
the same Queen right we're in the UK
Queen Elizabeth yeah I think in the US
we've got the same queen as well lower
than me by mistaken but I know in
Australia we've got the same Queen I
just came back from Australia now and uh
we make mention of this from time to
time anyways that's like a an Aussie
abutemia joke like uh so anyways going
back to the point that I was making
imagine now Queen Elizabeth is leaving
she decides to
go off on a holiday and then she places
a servant in charge of the people
what would the reaction of the people
actually be this is exactly what the um
right and he says to him haven't you
heard the statement of the messenger
foreign
and other people are put down
other people are put down other people
are humiliated because of how distant he
is from the book of Allah
and the point that he was trying to make
is
he has learned the Quran he has learned
the inheritance so why shouldn't I place
him in charge
look how Allah raise this servant
in the eyes in the eyes of the creation
and that's only after
he had a high status in the eyes of
Allahu subhanahu
right so if you want is that you want to
be honored in this world and simply
adhere to what Allah
you will see a lot of prosperity
somewhere where we can stop
um
so would you say that this is one of the
many traits of a high value man and
woman in Islam or would you say that
this is the
tree like the only one that's like of
like truly truly worth mentioning in
terms of a high value man and woman in
Islam but like we look in the Quran and
likewise the prophetic Sunnah of the
message
we find so many different traits
right but the messenger salallahu
himself made mention of that Allah
azzawajal referred to these men as the
region because there's a difference
between a male and a man even in the
Quran right you have men and you have
those who are better and the Sharia
makes a distinction of that
for many you got males right so one of
the first characteristics that
Allah made mention of
when referring to men as actual men
right in Surat Toba Allah
he speaks about the Hypocrites and how
they tried their utmost best to cause
this unity and this harmony amongst the
Muslims they even tried to build the
Masjid I was being spearheaded at the
time by an individual called
he was hypocrite
right so anyways
stand in this type of Mystery
foreign
they missed it that was established Upon
a taqwa
upon righteousness upon piety it's
foremost that you stand in look what
then Allah mentioned and here comes the
point that you guys are looking for
there are within this house this Masjid
men
they love to purify themselves
right this is the characteristic the
trait that is being mentioned they love
to purify themselves
what does that actually mean are we
speaking about purifying your outward
self now I'm without the shadow of a
doubt this would also fall under this
meaning no understand you should be
walking around just walk around right
he's thinking and huh and uh not using
scents and perfumes and so on and so
forth this is actually something that is
blameworthy
right somebody walk into the messages
and then the guy next to you has all you
know Bo coming out of his
this is actually detrimental this is not
something that is appropriate or
praiseworthy right in fact the message
he said that one should not come to the
house of Allah and he just ate onion
by this cause is harm to the people
around you likewise they call this harm
to uh the Angels they find it irritating
what can we also derive from this that
anything that is going to irritate
also falls under this this is referred
to Industry as yes analogy
say we're talking about you not coming
to the house of Allah you know with
onion in your mouth don't come to the
house of Allah's thinking as well
right because this is also something
that is going to
right irritates the Believers and
likewise the angels right so that's also
not something that should be disregarded
however that which here Allah is
specifically making mention of you
purifying the heart
and at the end of the day this is what
really matter this is exactly we want to
talk about right
purification of the heart he was making
mention of that before the uh the
podcast right Allah in the Quran he
quotes Ibrahimovic
he who begged Allah right
the day when you resurrect us oh Allah
do not humiliate me
this is Ibrahim Ali thought was some
asking Allah
not to humiliate him foreign
and also your children your kids are not
going to be of any benefit to you
the only thing that's going to benefit
you as Allah mentions and he makes an
exemption of this
except the one who comes to Allah who
meets him where they sound hot
what does it sound hot here mean
Brothers
right a heart that has been cleansed
from [ __ ] Innovations
and the sins
and this is what we're working towards
every single one of us right on a
day-to-day basis should be worrying
about how I can purify his heart
how I can keep it clean from anything
that is going to have a detrimental
effect on my hereafter
when you have what [ __ ] which is the
worst of sins
so associate partners of Allah there
isn't anything more greater than that
right you have Innovations introducing
newly invented practices into our
religion what makes our religion so
perfect brothers and sisters is because
it's been preserved right it's been
preserved our Dean has been completed
this verse that came down it was a Jew
one time that came up to um
he said there's a verse in your Quran
had it come down upon us Jews we would
have taken that
day as a day of Celebration
which I are you talking about
the day when I completed your religion
right the day when I complete your
religion so kind of Imagine right uh we
just accepted all of these Innovative
practices into our religion with our
religion be any different to the
Christians
you got gay pastors now
you've got some of their pastors that
are gay
and then here's what reading out the
Bible to them
sorry Brothers it just looks like the
lights are coming up here oh and there's
nothing dodgy going on here but uh
someone keeps switching off huh no no
there you go into places Jin free
it came back on series
one of the rooms so the point of the
matter is the point of the matter is uh
honey look how the dean their religion
has become so tempted with
right we open the door now for anyone
and everyone to just come and start
introducing newly invented practices
into our religion
our religion will just become no
different to this
can just be changed we can just be
tweaked and so on and so forth and then
the third thing of course brothers and
sisters is making sure that our hearts
are purified from the sins whether they
may be major whether they may be minor
this is what we really want to ensure
the meeting Allah
that's what really matters at the end of
the day because that's what Allah is
going to be looking at
there's another Hadith
does not look at your outer appearance
he doesn't look at how huge or how thin
or how skin you are no offense to your
brothers who work out huh
doesn't actually pay uh too much Focus
to that
right or what color skin you are or what
color skin you have whether you're black
whether you're white whether you're
orange whether you're tanned all of that
mothers and sisters along subhanallah
doesn't look at that
right
looks at your hearts and he also looks
at your actions
now that I said that does that mean I'm
discouraging everybody to work out or to
go to the gym now I'm not actually
saying that
right we spend sometimes how many hours
in the gym eight nine hours
very much a lot the brothers so strong
uh you can bench press 120 kilos
right he's not strong Allah
but then Brothers you know when it comes
to the federal prayer that blanket is
only 500 grams are we able to lift that
huh
that's very very important that imagine
we just spent a fraction of that on our
hearts on our relationship with Allah
we'd go a very very long way and of
course Islam also encourages one to be
strong to prepare himself
right so I'm not disregarding that at
all but I'm saying what really really
matters in the eyes of Allah azzawajal
is the purity of your heart
right when you really think about it
brothers and sisters when an individual
does these filthy evil acts would we all
agree that we all stem because of some
sickness in his heart
think about it for a moment guys right
the individual who starts spewing all
this nonsense after having embraced the
ideology of atheism
didn't all start with something that
subtle results
it started with his heart and then all
of a sudden he started projecting on his
limbs
that's the reality of the matter
likewise when you look at these
feminists
this belief settled in our heart and
then she started spearing all of this
evil all of this nonsense that's coming
out of her mouth
the whole world Brothers right you could
see is a run on a belief China doesn't
do whatever it does except due to a
belief
America doesn't do what it does except
due to a belief when this heart becomes
corrupted you see that the limbs they
follow suit and again this is exactly
what the prophet salallahu said indeed
inside of your body there's a piece of
Flesh
if that becomes rectified everything
else becomes rectified if that becomes
corrupt everything else will become
corrupt as old what is this this is the
heart
right this is the heart
um
that makes sense guys so this is maybe
uh the first trait that we can make
mention of you guys want to add anything
you guys want to say anything
for the low huh
you guys have that makes sense
I don't know it makes sense
I don't have anything against people to
go out and work out huh someone's
listening is thinking oh this guy's
telling us not to go to the gym now go
work out
huh muscle yourself up
I'm not saying that you shouldn't
however if this is now going to affect
your relationship with Allah
simply because you're around women or
dressed in whatever they are dressed
with you know with all that type stuff
this is of course without shadow of a
doubt it's not going to have an impact
on your heart
now which you look at everything that
you keep looking at brothers and sisters
it has a direct impact on an
individual's heart that black dot and
another black dot all the way up until
your heart has become so blackened
you put good in front of that individual
he doesn't even recognize it
you just see him drowning in evil and
that is because his heart has become so
desensitized to evil and so on
would repent of others and sisters 70
times in a city 70s and this is the
problem
foreign
while at the same time we find ourselves
in these environments thinking that is
absolutely nothing wrong with it
this will lead us to the structure every
time when we see whatever we shouldn't
be looking at it is putting that black
dot onto our hearts which then has
consequences some very serious
consequences
imagine Brothers right I had
brothers and sisters message me in the
month of Ramadan
saying what I committed dinner in the
month of Ramadan imagine in the month of
Ramadan they committed
how do you think this happened let me
ask you guys honestly tell me what you
think how do you think they committed
Zina in the month of Ramadan and I would
even ask them did you know her or did
you know him before the month of Iran
they would say no we didn't know we won
another how do you think it happened so
quickly in the month of Ramadan
remember this
is not sure
did they know it was no or did they not
know who's you know no of course they
knew it was you know they knew that they
shouldn't be doing dinner but how did it
now reach this particular point where
they're committing dinner in the month
knowing that they shouldn't be doing
this in the most sacred the state of
their hearts yeah it was in the heart
what happened was Brothers
what they kept on looking at on social
media one thing led to another
not lowering the Gaze he sees this fancy
profile picture it clicks on her profile
and the moment you click on her profile
brothers and sisters you are playing
with fire
one thing just led to another before
they ended up falling into what was the
unexpected
and innocent look led to what is in
subhanallah he kept on looking and what
every single time he hits his heart that
black dot hits his heart and he kept on
looking and you know some brothers say
as well and I think it's worth
mentioning I'm giving dawah to her
I'm giving darota she ends up giving
down to him brother
huh she ended up giving down with him
you know sorry to say but the hot
brothers and sisters is something that
you know should really be given a lot of
consent to at times you're feeding down
why are you feeding down maybe something
that I looked at maybe something that
I've done
right
we go into the effects of sins in the
heart I think we'll be here till
tomorrow
so uh
um so the end of the day brothers and
I'll conclude with this inshallah on
this particular point if you want
be pure
clean hot and take this advice
when he said
whoever wants a Pure Clean Heart then
let him make it a habit to always put
Allah before his desires and temptations
it gets tempting your friends are
calling you
the phone is calling you the truth in
the evil is calling you and you step on
your ego or you step on your whatever
they call it right you bite your tongue
right and look how you feel after that
this is one of the greatest mechanisms
to really purifying your heart put Allah
see how you feel after that
so I got a question for you so
let's see we're speaking to an
individual that understands this but
they're in it too deep so I know you're
talking about every time you look at
Haram you know
we don't want anyone listening to think
what we're saying is when you look at
that immediately it's in a note but what
we're saying is every single step
is something that basically normally the
reality that you added towards I mean I
think your audio is going sometimes good
and then sometimes it's just because you
let me know yeah no it's actually yeah
okay so my main question is what do you
say to those people what do you advise
those brothers and sisters that are in
it too deep where they don't even have
the willpower like
basically abstain so for example brother
that's desensitized for looking at what
you shouldn't be looking at maybe he
does them multiple times a day so what
advice would you have today because for
him it's like an addiction at that point
very wonderful right
and what I'm about to say brothers and
sisters who are listening right has
worked for a lot of people
right and these are practical steps that
I advise every single one of you guys to
pick
the first thing brothers and sisters
from the greatest of cures
and most effective is a drug
to make dry sincerely to Allah
right and sometimes we look at the
concept of a job Allah I'll see you know
I tried didn't
uh from the bottom of your heart while
you are Institute
right while you are in sujood
you make that since
the bottom of your heart
and this book and I think I'll you know
highlight it to the viewers there is a
book that was authored by Ali is called
the sickness and the Cure I honestly
believe this kitab here this book here
is the solution to a lot of the social
issues that many youngsters are
suffering from those who are addicted to
pornography those who are you know
committing fashion whatever have you
made it awesome this book was authored
because of a letter that was sent to the
Iman
he who himself was saying I'm so
indulged in sins
right and Uganda subhanallah the concern
this individual has this right or this
sender of this letter
of how much he's been trapped in these
sins and he's saying to him
if I don't find a solution out of this
situation this is not going to lead me
to destruction I remember when the chef
was teaching Us in the Haram
he was saying it seems like this person
has an addiction to something
from today
right and then the chef authored the
whole book
speaking about the effects of sins one
of the things that he mentioned in there
was that from the greatest and most
effective of cures is a drug
wallahi brothers and sisters how often
have I advise an individual with regards
to this particular concept
you may see that it doesn't happen the
first time but I tell you keep on going
keep making Dua right keep asking Allah
keep trying and I'll come on to the
second point every single time that you
commit that sin
stand up
make wulu
create two units of prayers and in that
studio you're making dry as well because
the closest that you drew to Allah is
where in your prostration position in
the sujood
foreign
he'll give it to you
right
it may not necessarily happen the first
time or the second time you may go back
into that sin and I don't care how many
times you fall back into that sin
I don't care what you are doing
sometimes the shaytan comes and Whispers
and makes you feel hypocritical
right how can you be praying when you're
committing Zina how can you be praying
when uh you're moving drugs from A to B
right how could you
see how he tries to trap you tries to
make you feel that you're you know being
hypocritical this is a trap from the
shaytan well lie I don't care if you're
a prostitute
and you're indulged in this sin
keep returning back to Allah
in that sujood
foreign
if Allah sees that good in your heart
he'll give you that goodness that you're
looking for
I'll tell you guys about brother that I
came to know about right
and uh he went on the camera with us you
know our brother
he has these uh
I think I know him right
yeah Dollar Man yeah yeah yeah he has
this Amazing Project where he takes
Brothers on the roads Brothers on the
streets right
some of the biggest drug dealers they
will come on Irma and you'll see them
doing 180s changing their lives around
I am a Hajj and armor operator my dad
sometimes takes people and I go with so
many different
um Homer groups however that armor group
is something else my Iman goes up when
I'm around these kind of problems
brothers are on the road who are really
you know the utmost best trying to
change their lives around we sit in the
Kaaba and they cry their eyes out I'm
trying to change please help
it has an impact on my heart it's a very
different setting and very different
group of brothers you know
so anyways I remember subhanallah that
there was his brother
they say he was running the drug
industry
in uh in East London
right apparently he has two houses as
well I know whether that's true or not
and one of the most expensive areas huh
the guy is filthy rich and he would even
pay for some of the uh Brothers to go on
Irma right imagine this guy is moving
drugs from A to B he realizes the time
of the Salah right he stops the car
takes out his sajada his Prema and he
starts praying on the roads
gets back into his car and then he's
moving the drunks
they say three or four non-muslim
brothers
right became Muslim because of him he
must be doing something right
that's why he has been caught by the
police we need to become Muslims as well
huh subhanallah and the Brothers Moving
drugs from A to B
ajib and eventually
guided his brother
foreign
it removes the filth and the evil from
an individual's life
right that's why I say I don't keep your
prostitute I don't give you a drug
dealer don't leave of the Salah
right it is the truck from the shaytan
going to you know tell you listen this
is hypocritical you shouldn't be even
praying coming anywhere near the Salah I
say if you go and pray
and see what happens you will see that
that filth inshallah will be removed
yeah
it's found a lot and and this shows why
tuskea is so important because that's
exactly what taskia does and I can't
wait to get to that part uh once you go
through the rest of the trades for high
value you know men women or people in
general but I do want to take this
moment to kind of emphasize this point
because
to make it really simple I think a lot
of people are going to struggle with
this point because as fight was saying
they're in too deep and what that looks
like
is they don't have a desire to want to
leave these things because they have a
desire for these things and it's kind of
like
if you take anything that you are
interested in a video game or a show or
whatever and you're sitting and you're
not really in the mood to play or to
watch if you start thinking about the
high points of the show and the high
points of the game you will suddenly
feel a desire to go watch it or play it
same thing with like men or women
if you are really uh you know not in a
really especially for men if you're not
in that kind of mood as soon as you
start thinking about things you will put
yourself in that mood and it's the same
exact thing when you're turning to Allah
if you're not thinking about Allah if
you're not reflecting on these things
you're still in that state of not
wanting to and it's uncomfortable to
think about being in that state because
right now you're in such a state that's
so far but as soon as you do it as soon
as you start thinking about Allah
as soon as you start reflecting as soon
as you read even a few Ayah from the
Quran you will feel that change
internally
and that is when you will desire to turn
to Allah you wonder how do people wake
up you know and go pray pleasure and the
measure it at you know early in the
morning 4 AM 5 a.m how do they even want
to do that it's because they're in a
completely different state and that's
not to say that they're better and this
is something that I learned
alhamdulillah thank I thank Allah every
day for this I I learned this when I was
younger I wasn't practicing I went to a
Catholic school I was 16 years old and I
came across one video on YouTube about
Elise and that's how I kind of you know
got back into Islam again I heard the
stories of yusufan Islam when I was a
kid but it didn't do anything for me or
to me and then when I I saw this video
about Ibiza I was just so interested in
these Concepts islamically everything in
my life everything I watched everything
even like my conversations with people
was always about Islam alhamdulillah
Allah at that time he made that exactly
who I was I was on a school bus on going
on a field trip debating people about
Christianity and Islam on the bus you
know the age of Aisha and like all these
things and that was you know what my
life was and honestly a part of me
misses those days because there was
nothing else I was really interested in
or worried about and that's not because
oh I was so great as a 16 year old it's
because that was all that surrounded me
and as a product of my surrounding
my life was just you know dawa Islam you
know being good to people trying to call
people to Islam and all these things
mashallah I love about it bro
so it's not about me the point the point
you know that's beautiful dangerous
surroundings
stays in a huge role also you know the
guy who killed 99 I'm sure you guys have
heard of the story you killed 99 and
then he went to
uh seek guidance right and he looks for
the one who's the most knowledgeable on
the face of his Earth
and he was directed to our monk who was
actually ignorant so he asked him is
there a possibility for me to be
forgiven he said no he ended up killing
him as well made 100 clean
right
uh and I subhanallah when he was
directed and steered towards a
knowledgeable individual he told him to
leave them nuns
right he told him to leave the lands and
he may well be that an individual is in
need of changing his surroundings by
leaving wherever he is
I I remember
my situations subhanallah and I've been
mentioning this in some of the lectures
that I've done
if my parents did not move me out of
London
one of three things were probably
happened in Allah
I would either be dead
or I would have joined Isis
or you're a family in prison by now
many of those around me they ended up
falling into well finding themselves in
one of these three situations my parents
they moved me out they went to a city
called Leicester City
um and uh sometimes when I think back at
this Hadith
see the effect of that like we had some
brothers I remember this last summer
that we went on I had the brother saying
to me he can't leave the house except
that he's holding a machete
he's carrying knives with him
you can't leave the house because of
what maybe the people in the arrows are
going to do to him
like this kind of individual is there
any other option for him except to leave
that area
he has to move out and Allah will open
doors you leave something for the sake
of Allah I'll give it up which is better
right hmm it's about a lot actually
reminded me of some ayats in the Quran
and I'm gonna paraphrase this so please
you know crack me if I if I misspeak at
all but I believe there's ayat in the
Quran to talk about on the day of
judgment Allah will punish a group of
people putting themselves into fitna
and there's also I believe Allah he
asked you know these similar people at
least people who lived in lands of like
you know fitna and fascia and all this
stuff
it will be us to them you know was
Allah's Earth not spacious enough for
you to migrate showing that if you are
in these situations not only should you
but you need to and if you don't then
that will be maybe a source of Reckoning
for you on the day of judgment
yeah without should have done yet then
buses
enough
for you to migrate
especially if that place that you're in
on them surroundings keep dragging you
back you have to learn to say no to
those around you right if we don't learn
to say no brothers and sisters we will
keep on being dragged to whatever
Direction it might be
I don't know this is interesting
it's allowed to take in um
yeah we all got a lot of gems reflective
state
when we're doing a podcast with someone
with with knowledge mashallah we all get
into this reflective state where we just
want to say and listen we forgot we're
recording yeah
that's what I said that's what I said
before we started I was like man I feel
like I'm just like sitting down I'm
about to get some knowledge
I love you it's an honor may I bless you
but uh if if that's all we can carry on
if there's other any other last minute
like practical tips or you know things
in the list that you want to add will
make someone however another important
characteristic of a high value man is
right I think that protected Dynasty
why is reaching a point my beloved
brothers and sisters right that one
actually takes pride in showing his wife
off
stuff wanting everybody to see her
like what's happening to
jealousy of men died when the jealousy
died within men Montes died within women
right that's very very profound is it
true without a shadow of a doubt
us men have forgotten how to be men
were too worried about what others are
going to say about us and what Society
has become right we're seen as
misogynists this is a term that's thrown
around the moment you say anything that
moves the feminist bone right the moment
you say something that moves that
feminist Bond you are right jumped with
these terms of or you're a misogynist
and you're overly protective and
um you're controlling yeah
how is the message how are the
companions
um let me share with you guys the Hadith
one time the message I'm just
paraphrasing him for the sake of time
otherwise I normally would mention it in
Arabic imagine
narrated that he once saw himself
in a dream right because I'm in a dream
and then he found himself in a gym
and then he saw that there was a woman
that was making although in a palace
so the message
who does this belong to this palace and
this
woman who's doing woohoo
it was said to him it is
occurred to him that he wanted to enter
this Palace
and then he remembered the protective
jealousy of um
this is why he's in the dream how can I
go into a palace when there's a woman
there and she's foreign
right so the mission Solario said I
refrained and I just left I went the
opposite direction
look at the understanding between
you know the men of that time
subhanallah
why I I not so long ago and I'm so
grateful to Allah this video this
lecture that I gave
picked up a lot of publicity it's called
cheating husbands filthy fathers and
premixes
how many of you guys came across it
right
in that lecture because you know it's
one thing quoting hola Hadith and ayat
and which is then going to fall on deaf
ears to many oh look at this guy you
know he's just backwards out of touch
with reality we're living in the 21st
century right men and women they have to
be mixing with one another and why are
you being overprotective for why are you
being controlling Habibi
it's not necessarily about me being
overprotective or as they say insecure
right this is what Allah mentioned so in
that lecture I read out
right the people the only victims these
are victims who fell victim to
gender mixing
what ended up happening to their
marriages
how the marriage is broke down how some
of them became traumatized and that is
because simply you did not follow a
basic instruction which was
not being alone with the opposite gender
messages
be aware of entering upon women
was asked about the brother-in-law
the message Allah they said the
brother-in-law is dead
the brother-in-law is dead
and he is the closest
to his brother's wife
you're being told that he's dead let
alone anyone else
so subhanallah some of these victims
they would say we would open our doors
for innocent Chit Chats
where men would come in with their wives
and in subhanallah ends up taking place
in the house of the woman that opened
these doors for people to come and
gender mix
this is when I really appreciate
knowledge honestly
like the other day I came across any his
video and the video was going viral on
Twitter
right I uh a man's getting married to a
woman I don't know if you guys seen it
it was literally kicking off man's
getting married to a woman and she
requested from him
to bring this popular celebrity guy or
something everyone that was her favorite
artist
favorite artist so he comes and hugs her
in front of everyone and she's getting
excited
on the wedding day and he's there
apparently
he's there apparently I don't know
whether he was trapping his own oppress
him huh but from what people were saying
oh this guy's watching enjoying his wife
being hugged by her favorite artist
so my question to you is where do you
think this [ __ ] fetish
started at like where do you think this
this came from because it's I don't want
to say it's a new thing because of even
growing up I'm I was born in the 90s but
even growing up we've seen that every
now and then some guys will like that
but there's an overwhelming amount of
men majority of Modern Men living in the
west today are like that they're you
yeah so you use the thumb the youth
which basically means
he's somebody that allows evil to take
place with his women Folk s bear with
him once again
I think it's one of those sensitive
lights
somebody who you know
doesn't have a problem with you hugging
his wife or hugging his sister doesn't
have absolutely no issues whatsoever
I think we can maybe narrow it down to
two reasons
the first reason is
right
you know Brothers when
the people stopped speaking about that
which the truth is you will see the
opposite
taking a stronghold
would you guys agree with that when you
look at the feminist movement
if you find the feminist movement that
ended up having such a stronghold now
you have the red pill movement well not
everything that I say is actually wrong
they are coming out of some things that
are correct
right however a lot that which they
propagate to be honest isn't in line
with the Sharia in fact it is contrary
to it
so you have a type of button a type of
ulcer that is pretty widespread and then
because
the truth is they're not spoken about
everyone's now scared to be canceled you
see some other nonsense that is going to
come out to counter that do you guys
agree with that 100 this has happened in
ancient times as well now when you look
at the whole lgbtq movement that's
actually become my favorite topic over
the last month or so
right wherever I go I speak about it
right
it is reaching the point brothers and
sisters that one feels embarrassed
it feels embarrassed to say his gender
he's asked about oh what is your gender
are you straight are you not the guy
thinks Thrice
of what he should say
is absolutely petrified to speak about
his gender how does it come to that
but he's thinking to himself what's the
agenda am I going to get canceled oh
this that nobody knows what they can
actually say
right people don't even know what they
can actually say
people don't even know that I could
actually hold on to my mothers and my
values and I can be vocal about it many
don't know and that's I put that down
too
the truth not being propagated and
because of that you will see the
opposite
taking a stronghold even
he mentioned
or the opposite in fact
when the Sunnah becomes weak the Buddha
the opposite of that Innovations they
will stop becoming what
stronger and we can say that about
anything he is speaking about the
Sunland I could be what watering down
the truth
and I had subhanah this is exactly what
happened in America you had some of the
leading figures coming out saying that
oh uh we agree with same-sex marriages
uh mother
uh
and the uh we we agree with same-sex
marriages politically but we disagree
with it morally
hmm
you have people listening to this what
do you want them to take away from this
well like some of the Americans you know
they they say to me you'll walk through
a university compass and you'll struggle
to find it a hijabi who's not wearing
lgbtq rainbow colors on her chest you
will struggle to find it
why do you think that is why do you
think that is can we put it down to it
they're not being enough people to
propagate that which is the truth
according to that which is right
not being firm with their positions
you'll see the opposite taking his from
home
[Music]
and also subhanallah you know the fact
that there was a lot of these Fair
monging tactics that were used anybody
who uses certain terms I mean this will
come out on him and completely
annihilate him
and to some degree you know that guy
a.tabutamia he put them in their place
right he actually completely shut them
down
and of course not everything
uh that he says it's actually wrong
there were some things that he said
which were you know in line with Allah
but to some degree he actually really
did put them in their place
but up until then right you had people
were extremely scared of being called
misogynist and you know against women
and and uh and whatever have you and you
see my point
so these Fair monging tactics that were
being used these jamming tactics of
being labeled bigots and whatever have
you yeah
they're really quite fair in a lot of
people's hearts you know to say anything
about that which is right yeah one of
our teachers brother uh Gabriel Romani
he often told us that it's you know the
programming the conditioning it's always
going to be there you know uh the
shaming fact they're calling us
oppressive controlling more American
always going to be there but it's when
we as ambassadors of Islam called upper
hand when we started bending down
and you're blurring out again is that
happening for you guys as well Romney
and Angel yeah I was like your mic is
underwater sometimes really yeah yeah I
don't know if it's a connection issue
let me try that one more time hold up
I think it's just how you're speaking
into it because when you put your face
up like that it goes back to
oh
you know you need to give me the link
for that mic yeah is it clear now
we have the same mic maybe maybe it's uh
it's the game
maybe maybe could be
but yeah
over about your recording time my bad
halim you know you know what's funny
right you know it's funny I did some
research on how all of this lgbtq stuff
uh started picking up in the 1980s
two Harvard graduates they use this
three-step strategy
in order to really push this narrative
you know this three-step strategy was
number one desensifies
you speak about an issue so much that
people become so desensitized to it
khalas okay we've got the point now
because they keep hearing it if I stand
on the pulpit and I'm propagating the
exact same thing week in week out even
if you don't agree with me the first
week after week number five your
subconscious they have accepted what I'm
saying
step number two using these jamming
tactics to label anyone who comes with a
descendant opinion
that he is this and he's that
they're mongering tactics
does that make sense they'll start using
these jamming tactics to label you
bigots to label you a homophobe and
you're this and you're that and
and you will be silenced
number three once that happens brothers
and sisters
convert
they will easily convert you I think it
was you guys right I think it was you
guys you guys done a reaction video on
that uh we'll convert your children
right yeah
um
I remember I came across that and I sent
it to so many different people I mean
not this not you guys reaction but I
think I may have searched it and then I
came across you guys reacting on it at
least some brothers are bringing this to
life
right we got so much hate for that I
remember and what was it from the
Muslims
they're probably American Muslims so
it's serious right
finding America here in the UK we're a
lot more conservatives and nothing
against the Americans
in America well I had the average Muslim
will say to actually leave them alone we
are both minorities we need one another
they are made to feel that they
have to either be on the back foot or
they must have these coalitions with
them
this doesn't happen to us in the UK here
in New York we're a lot more
conservative and this is why I'm going
to every Masjid I could be speaking
about bunny rabbits and rainbows and
this topic comes in
well make mention of it Michigan doesn't
want to call me back again no problem
alhamdulillah so far 110 record of
always being what called back to that
same Masjid hmm even the messenger are
beginning to read this is something that
must be spoken about
right excuse me I'm not raising my voice
to anybody here or anyone else but I
just get extremely passionate about this
particular topic and I just feel like
not enough is being said not enough
people are coming out
I think about it how is it that this
minority group The lgbtq Movement are so
loud when in reality they are what a
raindrop compared to anyone else
their raindrop in the sea because every
single one of them is playing a part
you see them using these hashtags they
come out they are vocal about what they
stand for and I just want to make it
extremely clear right that we are not
here to entice harassment or violence
towards any minority group we are just
quoting and we are just not stating that
which is happening on the ground every
single one of them is playing a part
brothers and sisters
being woken about what they stand for
but when it comes to us we're being made
to feel that we must be silent no you
don't have to be silent
this position that Islam has when it
comes to lgbtq right is not just
something that is exclusive to Muslims
this is also the view of the Christians
the other day I was quoting an election
how Torah Jews I think it was over 300
rabbis they came together and they
unanimously agreed that this is
something that's immoral and I'm just
quoting now this is something that's
immoral and harmful
they refer to themselves as Torah Jews
so this is not something that is just
like you know exclusive to Muslims we
have to really play our part
it's sad this is the reality right it's
sad because you know young men are
taking uh and rotate as Romans
I can put it down to not enough men not
enough Scholars coming out and teaching
the people how to be men
so when somebody like this comes out
they feel the need okay you know what I
never had a father to teach me I didn't
find anyone ever teaching me how to be a
real man let me turn to an individual
like this
right
so Yani every single one of us like has
a role to play in establishing the truth
stop being scared my brothers and my
sisters
even if you are by yourself and that is
because Allah
will be with you
Brothers let me ask you guys right when
you guys came out and spoke about this
song that was going viral
did you think that
this had a negative effect on whatever
you guys are
trying to push onto the public
nope
matter of fact I think I think I had a
positive effect yeah yeah nothing
no effect did your YouTube channel get
closed down huh and every single one of
you guys get canceled because these guys
have been X you can't travel you've been
in prison inside of your home no but you
know you know we actually did get we got
a lot of people and especially
Christians too saying you guys said well
we were too scared to stay Allah come on
and that is because Allah will be by
your side
because you're doing that which many
people are not doing and that is
standing up for the truth
and that's something that you guys are
commended for
so anyways going back to the Horizon
issue and I think this is extremely
important having that protective
jealousy isn't necessarily something
that
makes you insecure this is how Allah
instructed us to be
to be individuals if that protective
jealousy dies within you Brothers you
will see filth and evil taking over you
mentioned and then he says
he doesn't have religion you will see
the religion deteriorate
and his heart will die and then
eventually you will see right his
actions following suit
you know how you need body temperature
right you need warmth inside of your
body
otherwise you'll die as a human being
he's saying that protective jealousy is
no different to that
not that warmth that you need inside of
your body is
similar to that you must have that
otherwise your heart will die
subhanallah out of all the things that
he could have mentioned that keeps your
life he's talking about
talking about the protective jealousy
like that
um
you know it's crazy
is that every man has this like whether
the Muslim or not it's kind of like
instilled in us because even when I was
a Muslim I could feel that and then
when one so not submits but when one uh
suppresses this
because you live in a society where it's
told that oh you shouldn't be jealous
you know you should let your you should
let your woman do what she wants like
you should give her the freedom and all
this stuff it's like when one suppresses
this
the mental chaos that goes on inside of
you like you start feeling like less of
an individual and imagine like you keep
doing this more and more until now this
becomes normal for you and then now
you've just kind of like submitted
yourself to it and then now because you
can't stand for that because you can't
even express yourself because you can't
even be truthful well now This Woman's
walking over you now she doesn't see you
the same way now uh someone else is
walking over you and then it just keeps
going and keep going it keeps repeating
itself
so I just I think it's crazy man
like it's also subhanallah you say this
back in 2015.
when I would discourage the youth
right from taking these
uh rap stars and these celebrities as
Role Models I I think it was Kanye West
that really got the ball rolling showing
off his wife
everybody's trying to be like Kanye West
oh come and look at my wife
which is precious have you guys ever
thought about this point like this right
have you noticed that whatever is
precious
whatever expression is actually really
hard to get to
diamonds gems pearls degree that it's
very hard to get to even your bank card
is it easy for a pickpocket to just come
and swipe your bank card because you're
going to try and hide it right
everything that is precious Brothers is
very hard to get to
aren't are women precious
why is it that we're flashing them
around you wouldn't do that to your bank
card you wouldn't do that to your money
that you keep hidden in a safe why are
you flashing your woman around like that
all right where has your protective
jealousy gone
I and this is I honestly believe
something that needs to be revived
something that needs to be brought back
to life
it's not being overprotective it's just
her knowing her place and you doing your
role of protecting your women Folk
it's as simple as that and remember we
are governed by a Sharia
we are governed by Sharia the morals of
the people are changing as time goes on
I remember when I was going to Australia
there was a stopover at New Delhi right
and there was this Irish guy he just you
know decided to come and sit next to me
it was on the same flight as me
and I was like where you going it's like
I'm going to Australia by yourself he
goes yeah
because I was meant to be with my
girlfriend
right however
me and her broke up I was like why what
happened so we just you know I thought
maybe this opportunity now to bring him
closer to this time
and he was like I saw I I caught her
sending images to
any all of these other guys you know you
know
so uh and then she was like to me that
I'm being overprotective I was just
sending a picture of me I think where
did you draw the line when you're not
governed by Sharia when you don't have
morals that are divine
right you have things that were you know
considered immoral maybe 20 years ago
all of a sudden now they considered what
perfectly moral
so I said where do you draw the line
you allow your girlfriend to maybe dress
a certain way
what happens tomorrow if she decides to
walk
on the streets without value wearing
anything she decides to walk with uh
excuse me if I even mentioned in this
like she's barely wearing anything she
wearing a bikini for example why do you
draw the line
right you allow her to speak to other
men you don't have a problem with that
but the moment she sends a picture
you've got a problem with that where did
you draw the line
who determines what are considered good
morals and bad morals
even like when you speak to the atheist
right The Atheist they themselves can't
agree on that what is considered morally
accepted and what is not
so if you guys are different with one
another someone may you know you know
wake up tomorrow and say okay me killing
you is someone that is perfectly moral
the way you draw the line this is why we
have no option except except that there
is an external entity I.E Allah
who has governed us with a Sharia
who instruct us to keep certain morals
and certain things need to be what
removed from your life otherwise
whatever relationship you enter into you
will always have these disputes if you
don't have the Quran and the Sunnah and
the understanding of the companions
right that you keep going back to every
other day you're arguing with how are
you dressing like that why are you
wearing this why are you not doing this
why stop being overprotected no no
Sharia is this
right
sorry Brothers I know we just kind of
like went from one place this is one of
my favorite no this was one of my
favorite podcasts we ever filmed because
this was so beneficial it's it's
literally just like I was telling you
the comments that we got
once we made that video I'm telling you
these are the things that we want to say
but it's not that we're afraid to say
but sometimes we get too caught up in
our head like oh do other people think
like this am I the only one but the
reality is it's fitra
yeah and Allah has given us a gift of
one clouding the fitra and the least
that we could do is unite and show the
world that we all think the same it's
not abnormal it's not brainwashed or
barbaric or anything like that and we
gotta stand for Huck
yeah I'm the last anyone want to cancel
you guys they can just cancel me and
Shout out I'll leave you guys around you
guys continue
huh guys it sucks it sucks we gotta wrap
this up but unfortunately maybe we can
do another one but guys smash that like
button five thousand likes and inshallah
we will meet up with brother Mia in
person
for the last six years every year
somebody says to me we're going to
swallow your trip to Canada and I
actually give my heart to it it's going
to happen and then every single year
something happens every single year
even though after the Australian trip I
was meant to be going to Canada science
happens
if you guys are in Canada hopefully next
year some of the brothers will you know
sort something out are you guys in
Toronto or in Ottawa yeah we're near
Toronto bro
yeah
we'll be going to the UK inshallah my
man just revealed it just like that
yes all right guys if you made it this
far only you know
um inshallah look forward to a UK tour
coming up sometime inshallah
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]